what's going on guys today we're going
to be breaking down strong evidence in
both the microacademia manga and the
vigilante spin-off that proves the
origin of principal nezu has a direct
connection to all for one while it's
true that in the series so far nezu's
past has been mostly a mystery one thing
we've always known is that he was the
victim of several experiments at the
hands of humans and so when you combine
that information with the other clues
we'll be talking about you start to
realize there's no way this guy's as
squeaky clean as he tries to appear
there are very few times i've ever been
as certain about a theory as i am with
this so stick around till the end and i
guarantee you'll see how the manga is
telling us that the villains and the
principal have a history together before
we get into it don't forget to smash
that sub button if you haven't already
and remember there will be spoilers
ahead
okay so to explain the true origin of
nezu we first need to go back to chapter
270 in which dr garaki revealed some
very relevant information in this
chapter the doctor said that 70 years
ago it was him who came up with the idea
of the quirk singularity theory which is
of course the idea that corpse will
become so complex that regular humans
won't be able to control their power
after presenting this hypothesis he was
rejected by other scientists who said
that it was nonsense based on weak
evidence and garaki's life then
completely fell apart after that with
him being excluded from the scientific
community and becoming homeless despite
this it was all for one who helped the
doctor to turn his life around and he
gave him resources that enabled him to
begin his twisted experiments and off
one did this because unlike everyone
else he believed in dr garaki's theory
as i said the quirk singularity concept
was heavily criticized due to lack of
evidence so it stands to reason that
once he had the backing of all for one
the doctor would conduct research to
find evidence that would support his
belief in order for him to prove that
quirks would one day become too complex
to handle it first required a
fundamental understanding of what a
quirk actually is and this brings us to
the topic of mice in chapter 158 we were
introduced to the notion that quirks
might be a disease that might help to
spread across the world and to this day
that is the only explanation we've ever
gotten as to how these abilities
suddenly started appearing kaijusaki was
a strong believer in the mouse theory
and in a flashback he was seen
conducting his own experiments on mice
while he was researching the nature of
erie's power later on in the series
hirokoshi dropped yet another clue about
mice when he decided to make them the
symbol of the meta liberation army who
were a group dedicated to allowing
people to freely use their quirks what
this shows is that in the world of
mighty academia the idea that mice are
responsible for the origin of quirks is
being heavily pushed by the author
himself and currently there is no other
alternate explanation
bearing that in mind is guaranteed that
at some point in the past dr garaki
would have experimented on mice to
deepen his understanding of what quirks
actually are and in japan the word for
mouse is nizumi the word nizumi is where
the name nezu derives from heavily
implying that even though his current
appearance is like a mixture of lots of
different animals at his core he is or
was just a mouse this is where things
begin to tie together because number one
we've established the importance of mice
and why dr garaki would want to
experiment on them and number two we've
established that nezu is a type of mouse
who has been experimented on we're now
going to dive into the outcome of nezu's
experiments and how mycho academia
vigilantes implies he might be the ua
traitor
to start things off back in the day all
for one was understandably the only
person able to transfer quirks but in
the present day dr garaki has such a
deep understanding that he can transfer
quirks duplicate them or even store them
on chips purely using technology alone
that kind of knowledge is so far more
advanced than anyone else in the series
but it was only possible thanks to his
unethical experiments the first of which
would likely have been conducted on mice
besides them being important to the
origin of quirks they are very often
used as lab rats to test things out and
i believe dr gracie would have followed
that same process
i say that because even though the guy
is a mad scientist he has been shown to
follow some basic principles like for
example the time when he searched for a
willing test subject to have their
bodies enhanced to receive all for one
for that reason i'm sure that decades
ago as a test there would have come a
time when garaki wanted to enhance the
body of a mouse to receive a quirk and
that regular mouse eventually became
principal nezu i'll preface this by
saying that on nez's character page his
age is listed as unknown meaning the
idea of him being old enough to be one
of the doctor's original creations is is
very possible within this timeline
furthermore while there are several
humans that have animalistic quirks
there are only a handful of animals that
possess quirks themselves and every
single one of them has questionable
origins
in the vigilante's prequel of one was
the mastermind behind a group known as
the villain factory who conducted really
gross experiments on both humans and
animals in the hope of one day creating
a nomu that could defeat all mites
overall there were a few creatures that
the villain factory modified in the
series including an elephant and a panda
that were found in their lab a monster
cat that was given two doses of the
quirk enhancing drug trigger and an army
of sentient bees that were controlled by
a queen bee who herself was able to
inhabit a human host this means that
when we look at every single enhanced
animal literally all of them are
confirmed to have some connection to all
for one except for nezu at the moment
but in my opinion it's only a matter of
time until his backstory is revealed to
be similar
in a second we'll get into how this
means he could be the ua traitor but
first if you have any doubts about this
theory one question we should ask
ourselves is if the principle was
experimental in all sorts of ways in the
past what exactly were the results of
those experiments in chapter 66 it was
stated that there is no animal on the
planet who is like nezu and rather than
him being a freak occurrence is it not
more plausible that the experiments he
went through are exactly the reason why
he is so special
his body is unlike any other creature as
it seems to be a combination of a mouse
a dog and a bear like he joked about in
season 1 and his quirk enabled him to
reach a high position in society and get
close to all might something dr garaki's
other creations never would have been
able to do
it's specifically because of his
intelligence that the villains could let
him go off into the world and do his own
thing and in the process nezu became a
millionaire who was in charge of the
world's most famous hero school giving
authon a mole on the inside of heroes
society the principal even said himself
that he has no way of clearly proving
that he isn't the ua traitor so let's
examine how he's been working for afo
this whole time
at the usj kurogiri mentioned how they
were able to plan the attack thanks to
receiving a ua staff schedule something
the head of the school would of course
have access to that being said nezu's
actions around this time weren't
actually that suspicious as he sat down
and drank tea with almighty instead of
encouraging the hero to go to the usj
where the nomu is waiting to kill him
this opens up the possibility that
similar to gigantomaki and shirokumo his
mind has been you know manipulated in a
way where he has some degree of free
will but when he's called upon by all
for one he has no choice but to do what
his master says in that way nezu could
essentially be leading two separate
lives one where he is genuinely on the
side of the heroes and wants them to win
and another where he follows the orders
that are given to him courtesy of dr
garaki's experiments if this is the case
it would explain why nezu thinks heroic
thoughts even when he's alone because
his true nature is that of a hero it's
just that when he's called upon he can't
resist all for one anyway the second
time the ua traitor made a move was when
the villains received the location of a
top secret forest training camp which is
a place where only the teachers and the
wild pussycats were aware of again this
is a scenario where nezu had access to
information that the league of villains
wanted and as a direct result of the
attack the students were moved into
dorms something the principal said he
wanted to happen for a very long time
what makes this more suspicious is that
once the kids were in dorms the
principal then paid out of his own
pocket to redesign the ua barrier in
such a way that it would be able to
counter shigaraki's awakened decay quirk
the problem here is that at the time
when he made this large personal
investment the decay quirk hadn't
awakened and there was no existing
evidence that such a thing would ever
happen he claimed he just relied on
intuition when he did this and given
that he's super intelligent you could
make the argument however the fact he
spent hundreds of millions of yen out of
his own pocket you know that shows that
this was more than simple intuition it
was more than just a hunch to do all
this nezu had to have been certain that
shigeruki's decay was going to awaken
before it happened and on top of that he
knew exactly what an awakened form of
this power would look like
in my opinion the reason he was so sure
of these things and why he was willing
to spend all this money is due to the
fact that as a creation of the villains
he had already seen the full potential
of decay in the past on at least one
occasion tomorrow's backstory proved
that decay was always able to transfer
from one object to another it's just
that for most of his life he
subconsciously limited its potential but
anyone who knew shigaraki as a child
would know what the awakened decay could
do
additionally if you believe the theory
that decay was given to shiguraki by
alpha 1 which i happen to believe then
that means someone else in the past also
had this same power which is another
reason why nezu would be aware of his
full potential
as the principle he then did everything
he could to counter against this threat
but if he is truly a puppet of the
villains like kirigiri then everything
he's done might play into all one's
hands for example we know that the ue
barrier allows the school to be
separated into individual parts which
are then sent underground meaning that
if the villains break in nezu could be
ordered to trap midori and shigiraki in
the same section of ua and then have
that section sent underground where
there would be no escape
anyhow to recap the whole theory might
seemingly have a strong connection to
the origin of quirks and would
definitely have been studied by dr
garaki while he was researching for
evidence to support his singularity
theory as garaki's understanding of
quirk's increase he would have begun
conducting experiments that laid the
foundations for the things he does today
such as transferring and duplicating
these abilities
in the case of nezu he was already
confirmed to have gone through horrific
experiments in his past so when we
consider the relevance of mice and the
fact that every other quirk having
animal has a connection to the villains
nezu was likely made by the doctor these
experiments turned him from a normal
mouse into a super intelligent hybrid
animal that was able to integrate into
hero society and become a secret weapon
for the villains at the command of all
for one the principal handed over
information that allowed his students to
be attacked on different occasions but
presumably he had no choice because his
programming is probably similar to that
of giganto machia or kirigiri on the
other side though nezu has a degree of
free will and for the most part he's the
person who wants to do good explaining
why he wanted all might to win during
the battle of kamino and why he
redesigned the ua barrier to counter
against the power of awakened decay with
all that said let me know what you think
about this theory in the comments down
below and as always hit that sub button
if you want to see more stuff like this
thanks for watching as always and until
the next one peace out